I'm ready to lose my money!
Let's go gambling!
Ah dang it.
Welcome.
Welcome to me fighting for my afterlife... in Toreba.
A system I have never used before.
I know people that have...
So I know that it is not...
It won't...
Scam me, maybe.
Just the claw machines, maybe.
Should have gotten a headband for your model too.
Hey, I like this one.
I made it myself.
Chill out.
I like this one.
It's been months, but I've finally gotten over my anime figure and Pokemon plushie crane games addiction.
Mint starts playing Toreba.
No, don't do it!
Don't do it!
I like this headband.
Thank you very much.
Thank you!
Happy Kami Oshiri day.
Thanks.
You're ready to lose our money.
Highly debated.
Because, okay, they have these on Mercari.
Okay, hold on.
Let me start at the very beginning.
Also, sorry Ashes, you did not win the gacha.
My town dodged 5 to 6 tornadoes.
Are you okay?
I think you need to move.
Or wait, maybe you need to stay, because your town is lucky.
It's my first stream.
Welcome!
Okay, let me explain from the beginning.
So, when they announced these Metal Gear crane game items...
a while ago, some time ago.
And they said that they would start in October.
So I was like, okay.
I was in October.
On October 1st.
And I went all over Akihabara.
I went to every single place that I could find.
Every single arcade in Akihabara.
That with a crane game.
And none of them had it.
And I was very sad and very disappointed.
She was in October.
Wait, is that what I said?
Oh, wait.
I was in...
I was in Japan in October.
You guys know what I meant.
Shut up.
Fellow Oklahoma-me.
Stay safe, you guys.
Oh my gosh.
But I was in Japan in October and I went all over the place.
I searched for hours.
Nothing.
I was so disappointed.
You know when these bad boys came out?
Oh, wait.
Maybe it wasn't these.
Maybe it was...
When did the tumblers start?
I know that the gacha machine, the gachapon one started...
Now I don't know.
What?
Well, regardless.
One of them, they released Metal Gear gachapons and they released these Metal Gear tumblers.
And they both...
Or maybe not both.
I don't know anymore.
One of them started on October 31st.
Which I'm like, seriously?
You're gonna say that it starts in October?
And then have it start on the final day of Octumber?
Oct...
Not Tumblr.
October...
Tumblr.
Yeah, they're tumblers.
You know, Tumblr cups?
You know the things that came before the website, you brain-rotted individuals?
Get off the internet, Octumbr!
Stop!
My god.
RT Ronin, thank you so much for the 20th.
What she puts on the head, man.
The brain rot takes over.
I can't believe I said that.
I've got Tumblr on the brain.
Metal Gear Tumblr's on the brain.
And so I went and checked Mercari.
Which as I do near daily, I see what Metal Gear things are on Mercari.
Almost every day.
And I went and I checked and I was like, I wonder if they have the Tumblrs.
And they do, obviously.
They had them up very quickly.
They had all four.
There's four of them.
They have one for Metal Gear.
One for Metal Gear Solid.
One for Metal Gear Solid 2.
And one for Metal Gear Solid 3.
Which one for Metal Gear is like huge.
Like first Metal Gear, that's crazy.
But they had them all for about 60 bucks.
Which I was like, that's really not bad.
I would spend so much more trying to get just one, probably.
And then I was like, yeah, but I have no satisfaction.
And so, you know, I want to win it myself.
I've never... I think I've won maybe one thing out of a crane game before.
And so I was just like, well, let me see.
I only know of Toreba.
I was like, I'll see if they have it.
And lo and behold...
It's the only thing I've ever searched on this website.
Look at this.
Oh my gosh, go away, advertisement.
Wait, why is this so expensive?
Why is it 4,000 TP?
What is a TP?
That's what I bought.
I bought 60 dollars worth of a TP.
Let's go tumbling.
Why are some of them different amounts?
I'm confused.
I've never played this website before.
Two.
Are you ready to sell your already dead soul to the Toreba demons?
Maybe.
Higher amount, easier game to win.
It's pay to win.
Wait, actually?
Different crane game difficulty?
Biggest advice I can give on Toreba is always go for the assist cranes.
With enough time and credits, you can brute force win prizes eventually.
Who was I with?
I was with Emuri in Japan.
And she tried getting a...
A Oshinoko plushie.
And with our powers combined...
The assistant had to literally put the doll on the edge.
The assistant had to come and put the doll literally on...
Like, so that it was tilting into...
So it was tilting into...
The exit.
The bowl.
What did you call it?
The hole.
So nice and condescending at the same time.
I know!
I don't know if that's great or sad.
It was very sad.
And guess what?
We didn't get it.
And they had to go set it up again.
We didn't even get it!
And we had to set it up.
We had to ask them to set it up one more time.
Wait, so...
So...
This...
This is the assist help.
Why is this a...
4000.
What happened?
OK, let's see what it is.
Oh my gosh!
It's a takoyaki!
Wait, so I pick up the balls and then I drop it and I have to get it into the center?
But it's 4000!
4000!
Supposedly those are easier.
They are not.
Look at this!
What if I get it first try though?
Wait, is this live?
Yeah!
I get to try in real time!
4k toilet paper.
If it lands in the ring then you win.
Right in the middle?
Eventually I would have to get it.
Wait, what's 4?
OK, hold on.
50,000... Calculator.
50,000...
Divided by 4.
Oh wait, sorry.
50,000...
Divided by 4,000.
I would only have 12 tries.
About.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11...
12, 13, 14, 15, 16...
There's 17 holes open!
There's more than 12 holes!
You guys, what if I end up spending like 60 dollars on... on what?
That would be ridiculous.
They can also stack on each other.
No!
They can't, they're balls!
Sorry.
Oh my god!
Who's using it?
Oh
my god.
Who's... Who's playing on this one?
Stop, it's mine!
You will get sniped?
No, you guys, stop it!
Don't snipe me, please!
I'm kind of invested in their progress though.
What if I press play?
Oh my gosh!
You suck!
Boo!
Get off the crate!
You suck!
Fill up the empty ones so she can one-shot.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
No!
Don't fill them up!
Oh, they're trying again.
Is there someone in chat?
Oh my gosh!
Oh, you got really unlucky.
You got really unlucky.
Okay.
Okay, I want to start in order though, right?
Currently in use!
These were all free until just now!
Are you kidding me right now?
No way.
I want to start from metal gear and then go up and up and up.
Sniping isn't entirely bad because they just use their credits and give up.
That just makes things easier for us to win.
Maybe.
Should I wait?
These ones have always been currently in use.
Ever since I checked on the site the first time.
Okay, I'm going to try this one.
They're still going.
That was so close!
Wait, what if I press play?
Okay, I'm in the...
There's music?
Holy loud.
Oh my God.
How
many times are they going to go?
I can't even switch the camera.
Yeah, fill it up until you have no more points.
It's so loud!
How do I turn it off?
Am I cute today?
Trick question, because it's always true.
Oh, am I cute today?
Camera debuff.
Oh my gosh.
How long are they going to go for?
The settings button?
Oh, here?
Please shut up.
I'm going to turn this down too.
What's that stamp?
Okay, now we can have our music back.
My jazzy music.
Guess who absolutely destroyed his Calculus 2 final today?
Thank you for existing.
Evan!
Let's go!
Congrats!
Can I turn now?
Minto turn, please!
I'm the one in the queue though.
I'm the one in the queue.
Are you done?
They are going to take it, you guys.
I bet this person is not even a fan.
This person just wants to be a reseller.
This person is just a Metal Gear Tumbler reseller.
Sending you my birthday luck with Big Minto.
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Yamuha!
Happy birthday!
Guys, I don't know if I'm going to be able to play.
I think this person is serious.
If you are watching this stream, can you actually let me try?
Oh my god.
If you end up winning it, I'm going to be so upset.
Let me try.
Let me in.
There can't be this many people who want... There's three people mining!
Who is this?
Bob said it's my turn on the MGS claw machine.
We're just watching this person.
This actually would be me probably.
Starting to trigger my trypophobia.
I don't have that though.
Chat's the one playing.
Eventually something will... Eventually I'll get to play.
Right?
But what if they fill it all up?
Oh my god.
Stop making snowmen!
Play the game properly!
School issue.
I want to play.
Maybe I should just go for the claw games.
I'm scared.
I
hope your package gets lost in the maze!
Man.
They tried 15 times.
Is that really how long it took them?
Cursed by the ghost man.
I guess let's leave.
I wanted to try that one.
Man.
Maybe this was a bad stream idea.
Maybe I'm just gonna go to Bergaria.
Maybe I'm wasting my money.
Let's see.
I guess we'll try this one.
Or what's the difference between...
So this is technically an easier one.
Let's try.
Let's look at this one.
What kind of thing is this?
It's the same thing!
It's the same one!
Play, but it's cheaper!
Ok, here we go guys.
John, welcome to Mambo Ship!
Ok, here we go.
Start.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, how do...what do you mean?
What?
I just go over?
Huh?
Wait, I just press over?
Wait...huh?
I'm confused.
I only have 15 remaining.
What do I do?
Huh?
Just tap.
Oh.
Huh?
Oh, that's really confusing.
I hate this one.
I'm leaving.
It's supposed to be...
Let me out of here!
Someone else can play it.
Get me out of here.
Oops, I think I went too far.
The rage quit.
In order to operate the crane and get the ball into the hole, press the action button.
Maybe they reset the other one.
I don't think I want to pay...
I can't even guarantee grabbing a ball.
Skill issue.
Holy moly.
Wait, these are all in use.
You motherfuckers!
Get out of my stream!
I should have never done this.
Now I won't be able to try a single time because you assholes are like...
What if I try instead?
I know Minto is trying to make content, but what if I just instead do it?
Get out of here!
There's two people...
Oh wait, this one is like...
This is even more difficult!
Oh my gosh, what?
How are you supposed to grab it with a single hook?
What?
This is the cheap one?
Why didn't I do any...
Nine remaining!
You guys, there's no way.
Please.
You guys, this is...
There's only nine.
Who is grabbing these?
You don't grab, you push.
Wait, what do you mean?
You just push the box over?
Guilty in taking one.
I give you a break with the eShop codes.
There is no mercy today.
I know, I literally cried about how good you guys were the other day.
And now...
Now you...
Wait, now there's three people waiting.
Now there's seven people browsing.
Oh my goodness.
Should I get in line?
Ok, I'm in line.
Ok, you can stop playing now.
I don't think it's moved at all.
I understand your anger, but I really want one.
How about you go to Mercari and buy it, ok?
Actually don't, because I'm gonna have to purchase them anyway on Mercari.
Thank you.
So excited for the Mercari JP browsing stream.
You'll just see my history, recent history is just Metal Gear, Metal Gear, Metal Gear, sometimes Idols, Metal Gear, Metal Gear.
I can't even tell if you're taking this seriously.
I think you're wasting your money, buddy.
I think you got...
I think you got it, come on.
It's time to stop.
It's not coming home.
Oh my gosh.
Maybe this guy has... Maybe, yeah.
Maybe I shouldn't do this one since I have bad depth perception and this guy probably does too.
This one looks really hard.
I'll give up my machine once I win three more.
What a nice five round.
I believe in you, Mint.
You got this.
Thank you, Prince.
Oh my gosh, this is so funny.
I think the Wisps are saving you from gambling.
We're nice.
Oh my gosh, you tickled it!
You did it!
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice tickle.
What does assist 65 play mean?
They come and help you after 65 plays?
Oh my gosh, they did it again!
Maybe they were just...
Maybe before they were like...
They were hiding their power level, you know?
No depth perception because of the eyepatch.
The hand of God.
Do you think the other ones reset?
The 4000 ones?
I really want to try.
How is it not moving even a single bit?
How is it not moving even just a tiny, tiny bit?
I was listening to your summer podcast and got to the second one about the Minotaur while I was driving.
I learned so much.
Well, first off, thank you.
How do I say?
Arsloads?
Thank you for listening.
Glad you learned so much.
The loop is a trap, so you actually just have to push it?
You just, like, push it over with the hand instead?
I wish there was a chat in this so I could, like...
I could be like, push it instead!
Don't go for the loop, it's a trap!
That looked really promising, though.
I know the goal is MGS today, but the Hello Kitty cardcaptor Sakura plush on the front page is pretty cute.
I know, they always have such cute stuff.
Wait a second, hold on, I'm getting DMs.
Oh shoot.
Oh.
My.
God.
One of my friends is really good at crane games.
And this asshole...
Types in the group chat, can't believe I had to take off work to stream snipe someone in Toreba.
No!
Oh my god!
I can't believe this!
My friend, she was like, I saw the stream and was like, oh no, Minto.
This is so messed up.
Everybody, even my own friends are stream sniping me!
My own friends are stream sniping me!
I can't believe this.
The betrayal.
Oh man, I can't believe this.
We're just sitting here, this guy has probably wasted like a hundred dollars at this point.
And it hasn't moved an even centimeter.
Oh god.
What?
65 plays.
Friend.
I'm in tears watching this.
Oh my god!
Stop guys!
I can't.
I'm watching someone go into madness.
They're so determined.
But it doesn't work.
I'm in literal tears right now.
Oh my god.
Good content, Minto.
No, I'm not even a tickle.
Let's see the side view, everybody.
Oh my gosh.
It doesn't... Oh my god, here they go again.
Oh ok, nevermind, that's it.
Going back to the center.
Alright, let's see you go.
Oh wait!
Is it a different person?
Did they give up?
No!
Oh no, I'm position one now.
I don't think I want to try this one.
Wait, what was that?
Was that a sticker?
If you're getting stream sniped, it's time to add delay.
Competitive crane gaming.
What?
That's so cute.
Wait.
Oh my gosh, I did one too!
These are little stickers down here.
Oh my gosh, how cute.
Is there such thing as an absolute timeless friend?
Yeah, the mascots are very cute.
Ok, you guys, let's strategize.
So, when it's my turn, what do I aim for?
Do I aim for...
What if I can't get it as far as to push it, you know?
Try budging it in the corner.
Like, on the plastic tab hole.
It's my turn!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
It's my turn!
Wait, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
The screen can only do the tag.
Got it?
Aim for the edges of the loop.
Oh,
I think I went too far.
What?
Oh, where did I hit?
Wait, oh wait, I didn't get this!
I didn't get it.
There's a lag too, yeah, yeah.
Boing!
I don't know if I...
If I...
Oh gosh.
OK, I'm looking at the...
I was not too far enough.
Over.
OK.
The arm doesn't open up very wide.
I probably should have been studying the last guy.
I probably should have studied what he was doing...
Instead of just making fun of him the whole time.
OK.
Turn!
Oh, turn!
I'm gonna go for the inner.
Wait, I think my...
My thing lagged!
I got scammed for real!
No!
Of course they have no angry ones here.
That was such a bad lag!
No way!
Stop!
You guys suck!
I wonder if the other one is reset.
Guys, I'm not an idiot like that first person.
I know when to quit.
Because it's a scam.
Wait.
This Miku is so cute.
What else do they have up here?
What is this?
Cute.
Oh my gosh.
What's a metal cleaner?
Rude camera!
Get the shark outfit?
I want the giant shark costume, please.
You don't want the duck pajama?
I also like the boo sensor light.
These are really cute.
The card capture sakura.
And then the Minecraft...
You guys are kind of blocking it, but the Minecraft plushies.
Teresa.
Teresa, Teresa.
This is nice.
Multi-rack.
What is this?
Storage style compact heater?
That would be perfect for winter.
An avocado.
Thanks.
This Yui is so cute.
Okay, I'm not getting... I'm resetting my eyeballs.
Miku noodle stopper.
More giant shark.
I'm convinced nobody wins those and actually everybody just goes for the 4000 ones.
I think that's the meta.
I'm convinced nobody actually wins the crane games.
Exodia.
Oh my gosh.
I got a package recently from...
What con was it?
I think it was the Texas convention I did.
I finally got the fan letters and things like that from that.
And someone gifted me a bunch of Yu-Gi-Oh cards.
And for the first time ever, I own all of Exodia because of that.
So if you were the one who gifted me all of Exodia, thank you.
I was like opening it and I was like...
Like it first started with the hand and I was like...
No way.
It was so good.
Okay.
Play!
Alright guys, I know it's 4000.
Oh my gosh, it's completely empty.
That person robbed me.
Okay, start.
Is that all I do?
I'm scared.
Wait, how do I move it?
Where do I move it to?
Okay.
Oh
my gosh, I'm feeling the rush.
I'm feeling the high.
Oh my god!
Please!
Oh my gosh, it was so close!
You guys see that?
M That was so close.
Pure skill there.
Yeah, this is the skill.
This is the skill.
Oh my gosh, I almost didn't get a ball.
I feel like the scam with this one is that it's very easy to grab the ball.
No, I think you end up spending probably less money on this.
Just because...
It eventually has to go in, whereas...
Which way does it move when I do this?
Which way does it move?
I can't tell.
Okay, I have to go back more.
That was so mean.
Holy moly, it was so close!
Show me the back!
Thank you.
You guys stop it.
What did I...Why are you making fun...
So close!
So close.
Show me the back!
Okay, nice.
It's designed to give you hope, Minto.
Then take more than any other game?
I don't think so.
I think I would spend way more money on the crane.
How
much is that tumbler in total?
100 maintenance.
Restocking prize.
Prize confirmation?
Hold on.
Oh wait.
Hold on, don't look.
Machine prize number.
Wait, which one was this?
Wait, how do I know which machine this was?
You guys, it's my business email.
Chill out.
That email is literally on my Twitter.
Don't worry.
Literally, that email is on my Twitter.
Anybody has that email?
Wait, how do I know which one it is though?
It's saying it's in the cart.
Oh it is in my cart!
Oh my gosh!
You guys!
Tumbler!
Tumbler A in the cart!
Oh my gosh!
Yippee!
Alright.
It took me way less tries than that first guy too, so...
To you, mister whoever it was.
Alright, hold on.
Let's go back to...
Now we can go to Metal Gear Solid.
It's beneficial to ship them all at once.
Yeah, I'm just going to keep it in my cart.
Can I go back please?
There we go.
I'm just going to keep it in my cart.
And then...Yay!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, it's on the front page!
It wasn't before!
Is it because we made it so popular?
Why is it 1500 TP now?
Excuse me?
Inflation?
Wait!
What is this?
Oh, this is like a real crane game.
This is like a real crane game.
But we already did a Metal Gear Solid.
We want Metal Gear.
We want Metal Gear Solid.
Wait, can I choose if I win?
I like how the browsing just goes up every time.
You guys are so silly.
It's based on the one for the display.
Oh, so A.
Can I ask them to change it?
Excuse me!
Excuse me staff!
Sadly no.
It's ok.
We'll just go back to...
We'll just go back to the...
The search?
Wow, I didn't think it would be on the front page.
That's so exciting.
Now everybody will see the Metal Gear Tumb...Oh no, now everybody will see the Metal Gear Tumblers.
Oh no!
Wait, is it because I made it popular that they put it in the thing?
Is it because they were like, oh, lots of people are going for these Metal Gears?
Probably!
Oh, Trendsetter!
Holy moly!
Guys, look at our influence.
We put Metal Gear on the front page.
Good job everybody!
You did it boss?
No, we did it!
All of my... All of my successes are our successes.
That's why I say, like, whenever I beat a boss, I'm like, we did it!
Because we all did it together.
Yeah.
And all of your failures are our failures.
Yeah!
We are all one.
We are the hive mind.
Yeah.
When something... When, you know, when something bad happens, or rather, you know, maybe something weird happens, it's all of us.
One for all and all for one!
Do we also have to take the blame for the slide puzzles?
What's wrong with the slide puzzles?
Alright, so Metal Gear Solid.
That's B.
Restock it?
Wow!
Wait, so what is this one then?
It's always been currently in use.
What are these?
There's so many of them.
Select the machine you wish to play.
Wait, what are these?
This one looks not so bad.
It's just like a little tag, right?
These are general machines for general prizes, but you pick the prize.
Wait, so I can... But I've picked it, so I can just do what I... Oh my gosh, there's only four remaining.
I'm so scared.
Get some of that Metal Gear freaky made.
Oh, thank you!
Which one is the easiest, you would say?
Which one is the easiest, I wonder.
Soccer!
Are you winning me?
I am, actually!
This is truly our Metal Gear.
Not the 1000TP.
50,000 TP!
Why is it so expensive?
What?
This one is like a... Hold on.
Where you knock it off, the thing, right?
This one doesn't look so bad.
It's 2,000.
I think it's okay.
Takoyaki and some of the tool arm cranes.
It's grindy, this one.
Cheapest, the harder to win.
Yeah, yeah.
You think it'll move at all, I wonder.
My depth perception isn't very good with these games.
Takoyaki wasn't for me.
Wasn't there a takoyaki for this?
Oh my god.
Sir Takoyaki.
Takoyaki was so expensive, though.
Takoyaki is very, very pricey.
I wish there was like a...
Well, I guess 2,000 is the in-between.
What about this one?
Oh, did she win anything yet?
Maybe let me write a thing on the bottom.
Let me say... Hold on.
ViviCorn, thanks for the five gifted!
Number of tumblers, one.
One out of four.
There we go.
So what do you do with this?
Wait, first you have to scoop the ball and then you have to let it drop?
First you have to scoop the ball?
You have to be able to scoop it?
And hope it gets into the get zone, yeah.
Someone browsing, try this for me please.
Someone try... Someone looking at this, please.
I want to watch... I want to sample it first, please.
Go, go!
There's four people browsing.
Oh my gosh!
You guys are so...
You gotta scoop.
Scoop it.
Oh, you're so close.
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, if you win this...
If you win this, you have to... You will be the luckiest person ever.
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
That was naughty.
That went completely a different direction.
Okay, I'm so sorry you tried that one.
The ball is drunk.
That one was really bad.
Oh, you're gonna try again?
Okay, I'm rooting for you.
That one was so...
Oh my gosh, it was so naughty.
It just went completely a different...
It was like, I'm making it.
I'm gonna make it.
Nevermind.
Again!
And you can't determine where it goes in the middle, huh?
Oh, these balls are weighted.
Look at that!
Do you see how weighted that ball is?
Oh my gosh.
KZ Raptor, thank you for the five gifted.
Wait, you're gonna try again?
Seriously?
How do you even assist in this one?
Same direction too.
Yeah.
It's so weighted.
It's personal now.
I believe in you!
The house always wins, everybody.
The house always wins.
Yo, that's so messed up.
That one... Okay, you guys...
Stop trying!
It's impossible!
I don't think anybody has ever won this ever.
How are you supposed to even?
I know I'm not in the queue, I'm just watching.
Oh, watch from the side.
Look, they decorated it so cute.
So you just think it's nice and harmless.
I don't think you can choose to put it anywhere else than down the middle.
I think it automatically does it for you.
These are the only two times you get to manually...
Oh god, it hurts!
It hurts!
Thank you for the super chat.
I hope you're having a good day too.
Oh my goodness, I can't watch this one anymore.
It hurts.
It's too painful.
There's still four remaining.
For things like this, it's like you push it through, right?
For ones like this, you have to kind of shove it through the...
The thing, right?
You have to kind of push it.
At some point, yes.
Gotta give it a good poke.
The definition of insanity is doing the same thing over and over again and expecting different results.
You tilt it until it's a good position, then you push.
Look, it looks really wide around here.
What is this one?
Oh, this one you just lift up and...
This one's like legitimate crane game.
Where you just get it into the hole, isn't it?
Oh, my depth perception?
I thought it was right on top of it.
Oh, my gosh.
Legit, sure.
What's J-Claw?
What is a J-Claw?
Let's give it a try.
OK, I'm gonna try it.
Start!
Oh, OK.
One little poke.
And then, yeah.
Oh no!
I tried to account for the leg.
And I didn't do enough.
OK, hold on.
Let's redo, redo, redo.
Redo, redo.
Alright.
Let's see if I push it at all.
A smidge.
A tiny little bit.
Tiny, tiny bit.
This is tough.
OK, I'm gonna try and get it to like...
There.
Let's see if I can get the ear, you know?
Yeah, it's a grindy one, huh?
Uh...
Did I even...I'm not even moving at all.
OK, hold on.
Smidge!
Tiny, tiny!
And then...
Do the...Oh!
Oh no, I think that might be OK.
Did I move it any closer?
Do you think I moved it any closer?
Still forward progress.
It's moving tiny.
Was that too much?
I wonder.
You guys!
That was a big hop!
Oh my gosh!
A little, little, little, little...OK.
Oh, maybe that was not enough.
Shoot.
I don't think it was enough.
No.
I think they won.
The ball won.
No way!
I went and checked and it's in the basket.
No way.
Oh gosh, I'm gonna have to...Oh gosh.
I'm gonna have to get more TP.
More toilet paper, please!
Wait, I just realized, getting over this part, it's probably sticky.
I think this part is probably sticky, huh?
Oh no.
I just noticed.
OK.
I'm like literally just...
Oh my god, I've scooched it over just a tiny, tiny bit.
I feel like someone else is gonna grab it though and there's only four left.
I'm gonna lose out.
No!
For this one, I make the first press longer so the claw has to push the back over more.
I think I get it.
You can keep your spot in queue?
Wait, how do I do that?
Purchase a TP.
Is that keeping my...Oh, it kept my spot!
It really did.
It gave me lots more time.
OK.
I'll do...
So I initially spent $60.
That's how much I initially got.
So I'll get like the $35 one.
Oh good, I saved my credit card.
Oh good, it saved my credit card.
Alright.
Transaction complete.
Thank you.
Alrighty.
Thank you for the $80!
Stop it, don't...
Don't...Don't...Don't...Don't...
Wait, what's the word?
Don't reward my gambling!
I really like the new model and the eyepatch.
But I love the classic Minto gear solid headband remains.
Of course!
OK.
Sorry for those waiting, sorry.
Oh TP, but thank you!
Iris, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Enable, yeah that's the word.
Fuel, fuel, yeah.
Alright, start.
Alright, maybe like that much.
Oh that was a good shove!
Nice!
Toilet paper fight.
No good!
Thank you!
I honestly considered turning off super chats for this stream because I was like...
I don't want people to feel like they must...
Uh oh, was that too much?
Was that too much I think?
Shove!
Shove, shove, shove, shove, shove!
Yes!
Oh my gosh, we're inching it, we're inching it, we're inching it.
I'm scared now.
Because I don't know how much I need to go over now.
Guys that was so good!
Oh my gosh you guys, that was so good, that was so good!
That was huge!
We reached leaps and bounds!
OK.
Start.
Oh, that one was not so good.
That one was not so good.
OK, we need to redo that one.
Oh no, I don't think I went enough.
This side is tricky for me.
This side is tricky.
Nothing.
Actually I feel like...
Good luck, thank you!
Thank you Mew!
His ear, he's like a weird shape, right?
He's like kind of like a...
Hey!
Oh, I thought that was a sticker.
I thought someone sent a sticker of them falling asleep.
I was like, stop BMing me!
Like, snore, hurry up!
Oh my gosh.
Actually, OK.
This might not have been the move, but I'm gonna try it anyway.
Oh, I'm such an idiot!
I'm an idiot, I'm an idiot.
OK, I'm an idiot.
I went the wrong way.
BM stands for badminton.
I went backwards a little bit.
I think I went over too far!
This other side is so tricky.
This side is so tricky!
Stop it!
I went over too far again.
I think I'm gonna try and go to the cat's eye.
That's tough.
Keep going on the side closer to the claw.
Thank
you for the super chat!
Toilet paper.
Is she playing a generic game to win the specific MGS prizes?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you for everybody.
Stop!
Why?
Don't send that!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the super, but no!
Please, toilet.
Thank you, but no!
I think I went too far over.
Why does this ghost use so much TP?
This is hard.
This one is difficult.
Guys, I don't know where to go from here.
I wonder if it's the bar stopping it.
OK, I'm gonna just keep to the left again.
To the left side of it.
Did I go over too far?
You guys, it's not moving anymore at all.
It's not moving anymore at all.
Oh no!
I got so far.
I think it's stuck.
Sticky surface.
Go near the ear, but which one?
Use the ears, but which one?
The
left ear?
One closer to the edge.
OK.
The lag.
Oh
my gosh!
Wait, we are so close!
We are so close!
I pitted on Albedo swimsuit.
Oh my gosh.
Which way should I go now?
To the ear again?
How do I even go to the ear again though?
Maybe I can...
It's so...
Hold on.
It's so goofy looking.
I don't think I went far enough over.
Maybe I should keep pushing the...
Why are there so many people waiting going up?
Maybe the same ear.
Maybe I can push it over a little bit more.
OK, where is the ear?
It's like right there.
OK, I'll try.
Maybe like there.
It feels really far over.
I need to go over just a tiny bit more.
To get inside, I think.
Maybe too far over.
What?
Oh my goodness.
I don't know guys.
I don't know if I can...
I don't know if I can go with that spot anymore.
It keeps rotating.
I don't know if I can go with that.
I think I need to maybe aim for like over right in here.
That's the goal.
OK,
maybe it's OK.
Oh no, it's not OK.
OK, I need to not...
OK, I need to more...
I don't think this one has assists.
I don't know actually.
Uh oh, I'm almost out of money again.
Wait, I've almost spent 30 bucks on this and nothing...
This sucks!
Maybe like the eye.
But I'll have interference with the ear.
I think.
Oh my gosh, my depth perception sucks.
Hey!
Chill out!
I don't think I can push it down yet.
I don't think I... Do you think it'll fall if I push it?
I don't think so though.
I don't think I can push it just yet.
Yeah, not yet.
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Shoot.
That's not where... Oh my god.
The camera angle threw me all off.
How am I supposed to grab it from here?
Guys, I'm not sure.
Like I don't know where to grab it from here, because I can't.
My depth perception sucks.
Shut up!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the Akasuba!
My wallet is now your property.
Other cheek.
Ok, other cheek.
Please stop spamming!
I know you're trying to help, but I don't think you can push it down yet.
I'm not going to push it yet.
Thank you.
Please stop spamming.
I'm gonna have to time you out if you keep spamming.
Oh god.
Maybe?
Oh!
The tiniest little push!
The tiny, tiny, tiny bit.
How is their crane game backseating?
You'd be so surprised.
Baby push.
I think I went too far over.
Maybe.
Too shy to ask, but it was my birthday a few days ago.
Is it ok if I have a birthday song?
Wow!
Jimmy!
Neutron!
I have to be fast though.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Jimmy Neutron!
Happy birthday!
Don't ever feel too shy.
What are you talking about?
Don't ever.
I want to get right in here.
But I don't... I can't tell where the ear ends.
It's too...
It's too tricky for me.
To tell, you know?
It's too tricky for me to tell.
It's
so tricky!
Maybe I should just try pushing it.
But the left side is so weak.
Maybe I should try just pushing it though.
Oh my gosh!
You're right!
I'm out of TP!
Thank you for letting me know.
I buy more.
Purchase TP.
Oh my god, this is so sad.
Alexa.
Play.
Snake Eater.
Okay, I went through.
Please recognize that I went through.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
How am I supposed to do this?
Oh my god, Miyu, stop, please!
Oh my gosh, thank you, but stop, please!
I really appreciate it, but stop!
Thank you, thank you.
Come on, hot dog.
First... Oh, timing try.
Okay, I'll try it.
1, 2... 1, stop.
Then second screen... Or say 0, 1, stop.
Then second screen 0, 1, 2, stop.
Wait, how fast do I do that?
0, 1, 2?
Or 0, 1, 2.
How fast do I do that?
How do I get it in two shots?
You guys, the Bolly roll one... My friend won that one.
How the hell did you do that?
What?
How?
I told you my friend is really good at crane games.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, so this ear...
And then stab it down.
Maybe?
I said hot dog, gotcha and gotchu.
So if I say chugacha I get hot dog?
Oh my gosh, I actually did.
That's crazy.
Okay, alright.
The ear here...
Did I go too far over?
I got it though.
I got it over a little more.
Do you think I can stab it?
Or are we still...
Not yet?
Okay, not yet, not yet.
Not yet, not yet.
Okay.
I need to get the other side though.
You need to get the other side though.
Oh gosh.
Oopsie.
Uh oh.
Do you think the ear is a good place to keep pushing?
Maybe, okay.
This is stressing me out.
I'm so sweaty.
I know, this stupid piece of hair right there keeps getting in the way.
It's driving me crazy.
I think I'm too far over.
I guess I just lobotomized him instead.
I just lobotomized him.
Do you spend this much on actual crane games in Japan?
No, I never play crane games ever.
So I'm just making up for it, you know.
Ahem.
I don't think this one has the assist.
Otherwise I feel like people would come in already.
Alrighty.
Yeah, he's got a little dent now in his brain.
Good.
He deserves it.
This hair, his hair is so annoying.
I need to go over just a tiny bit more.
I need to go over a tiny bit more.
Like there maybe.
I know the lag is...
Okay, I need to go over more, even more.
They
helped me out!
Yippee!
We got the assist!
So now I can just push it down, right?
Pity has been taken on us.
Thank you God!
Thank you!
Okay.
How do I do this though?
Don't push it back.
Do you think they'd help me again?
I'm going over!
I'm scared!
Yeah!
Let's go!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh!
We did it!
Yippee!
Everybody waiting left.
Two out of four!
Oh my gosh!
Is it in my cart?
Hold on, let me check.
First try!
Oh there it is!
Oh my gosh!
It feels so good!
I feel so good!
Oh, it is still there.
I was going to say they took it off.
Is anybody doing it?
Wait, what was that?
Oh, they changed it to D!
You think?
They changed it, but I don't want to go out of order.
I'm on C!
This one is really hard.
This is hard.
These are not that easy.
This machine is also grindy!
Hold on, there was something on the page that I wanted.
This!
Look!
Oh, I thought it was a ghost.
I thought this was a ghost.
Oh, it's gone now.
Nevermind.
Oh, they took it off!
They were like, oh, she wanted...
Oh, nevermind, it's right here.
My head is blocking it.
They were like, oh, she wanted D.
We have to change it.
Let's go back to the Metal Gears.
I'm actually good at those machines.
I feel like those are the easiest.
But my friends do have a hard time.
You guys, do we go back?
For C.
Limited stock!
Wait, they're all limited stock!
Wait a second!
Wait a second, please!
You guys, I have to get them first!
When did they all turn to limited stock?
What?
Every single one of them is on limited stock now!
Do we do this one with my last 4,000?
How long have I been streaming?
Only an hour and a half.
Oh my gosh!
Apparently everybody wants them now.
Everybody is into Metal Gear Solid now.
I was addicted to using free tries on this in like... They had free tries?
I probably spent less than 100 bucks and won somewhere...
Wow!
What?
That's crazy!
12 or 13 figures!
Oh my gosh, really?
I don't know.
What about some of the other ones?
I hope they have Ace Combat.
If there is Ace Combat in the co-op games, maybe.
I can't believe we got A and B.
I'm so happy.
There's free TP offers on the front page.
Oh, I see.
This one is only 500.
Wait, what does this look like?
It's only 500 TP.
And it's Takoyaki.
Oh!
You have to scoop and then...
Oh, I'm on Tumblr, right?
It's ok, I wasn't gonna try.
And it bounces on the yellow.
Scary.
It's only 500.
Should we give it a shot?
The Takoyaki pan is cursed.
I feel like I spent less... Ok.
Actually, I have no idea.
I wonder if I spent more on the Takoyaki pan...
Like, collectively.
Or if I spent more on... I feel like I spent more on that last crane game.
I wonder.
Don't worry guys, I was gonna go to C.
Don't worry, I just wanted to look at it.
2.5 times on the crane?
But, it felt more traditional crane game style.
You know?
I felt like I was truly at the arcade.
Actually, hold on.
I should put on arcade ambiance instead, shouldn't I?
Hold on.
I'm gonna put on an arcade...
I wonder if there's a good one.
Arcade ambiance.
Japanese...
It's gonna be like really loud though.
Ambiance.
Ambient sounds...
Oh, I hear... Hey Akihabara, thousands of game arcades, virtual tour...
Oh!
Arcade ASMR 4K for 10 hours.
Hold on, let me hear it first.
Are
you guys immersed?
We're so immersed right now.
Oh my gosh, an actual takoyaki.
I wonder.
What did I say?
This isn't a Japanese arcade though.
This is like a real arcade.
Hold on, let me go to Japanese arcade.
Hold on.
This one is from 8 years ago.
Can I loop it?
OK.
There we go.
One of the comments on this video is, there are too many cars.
Sad.
Oh, I hear all the cars.
Maybe the last one was better.
Let's do the last one.
Where did... Oh, here we go.
There are too many cars.
Sad.
Alright guys.
This one is...
This one is a true claw game too.
Oh, let's see.
This one is in use.
Let's see how they are doing.
Oh, it's a little... You can do it!
Four people are waiting on this one.
Nine people browsing.
Why are there so many people here?
Oh, it's a sponge.
Oh my... What?
Is this another streamer?
Oh my gosh, is there another streamer doing this who likes Metal Gear?
Limit!
Thank you so much for the superchat.
Thank you!
Who is your profile picture?
It's so cute.
What is that?
Made lilac?
Himeno... Oh!
Yes!
I've seen... I've seen Twinpail before.
I saw them at Heroines.
Yes!
They are so cute!
The other member with the two-tone hair is so cute.
They are both cute.
They are both very cute.
Oh, I think they messed up you guys.
We are giving them like...
They are getting some real performance anxiety here.
How do you do this?
You can hear Tetris?
I guess you just pick up the sponge, right?
I'm confused by this one.
Do you get it on the sides or do you get it into this hole?
Like what's the goal here?
Oh my god.
I think it's the sides.
Oh they can just push it then!
Oh my gosh!
Push it!
Push!
Oh, Minto is backseating.
I'm not backseating.
I'm encouraging.
It's probably what some of you guys think too, huh?
I'm not backseating the streamer.
I'm giving encouraging words of advice.
Push!
Did they stop?
Oh, maybe they are getting more money.
Imagine if you were getting more money and it just like slid.
It just was like...
And you go back to the machine and you are just like...
OK.
Alright guys, we got to figure out...
This one I thought was a wisp for a second.
I thought this one was a wisp for a second.
Is this one easy?
What is this one like?
This one... How?
How does this work?
You just pick it up?
You just pick it up and...
The claws must be so weak though, right?
I just finished making a fresh baked potato.
Yummy!
Crow, have a delicious potato night.
OK, I'm going back to the...
I'm going back to this one.
Oh my gosh, limited stock!
We are going back to the Takoyaki.
Takoyaki time!
What the...
Oops, wrong one.
Just kidding.
What's really missing are those singing big clapper...
Wait, where is the Takoyaki time?
Tako... Oh, up here.
Takoyaki time!
Let's play baby!
Let's play!
Grab the ball and see where it falls.
Oh my gosh, my...
His grandpa used to have one.
How did that happen?
Seriously?
The cat picture.
OK, we got one.
And...
Drop!
Guys, my heart...
My ghost...
Oh my gosh, I felt like a heart almost just happened.
If my heart could stop again...
It wouldn't happen that moment.
So close.
Holy moly.
What?
That's two times in a row?
Are you kidding me?
Or not in a row, but seriously?
Who is laughing at me?
This is ridiculous.
Look at the bamboo ship.
Thank you.
This is ridiculous.
What is this?
OK.
I thought I almost didn't get one.
For real.
OK.
I am.
Should have done the 500 giant one.
True, right?
True.
Oh man.
OK.
Please.
Please!
Where did it go?
Wait, I don't even see it.
I closed my eyes for luck.
What happened?
You guys know it didn't.
It didn't bounce out.
No way!
I closed my eyes for good luck and it bounced.
Wait.
Oh no, I thought they refunded me for a second.
Of course, that would be too kind.
No way!
OK, I'm going to buy more.
How much should I buy them?
I'm genuinely impressed, but maybe don't close your eyes next time.
I think if I...
If I win this one...
And then I...
What's the word?
I can at least buy D, you know?
On Mercari.
It's a business expense.
It's fine.
Wait, where did the balls go?
Where should I go?
Maybe like right here in the front?
Am I not going to get any balls?
Oh god, please.
Please let me have a ball.
TWO BALLS!
Oh my god!
This machine in particular is absolutely haunted.
TWO MORE BALLS!
This grandpa used to have one of those machines.
No way!
How is that possible?
Excuse me, I won the machine!
Mint only rules natural ones and natural twenties.
I can't believe that happened!
How did that happen?
Please give me the confirmation!
This is insanity!
How did we do it?
Mint two balls phantom.
How did we do that?
The blue button.
Prize confirmation.
Oh wait, I don't think I have to do that though.
It usually just shows up in my car.
Hello!
Mint grabs two balls then two more.
Call me Vulcan.
Wait!
WAIT!
What do I do?
I still get the prize?
I do?
OK.
Hold on.
I'm going to do the prize confirmation.
I have to fill it out.
Hold on.
I don't know what the machine is though.
Prize confirmation.
Confirmation.
Machine slash prize.
This one.
Prize confirmation.
Confirm.
I have it caught on stream!
Yeah, they have the video.
It's OK.
I have it caught on stream even.
I can send them this stream.
OK.
Well they knocked it out.
Good job dummy.
Yeah, we have video proof.
We have video proof.
I can get out of here though.
I'm leaving.
Oh my goodness.
Don't get scammed by claw machine.
I still only have two things in my car.
I don't know what I was supposed to put with the...
With the claw machine.
I just put the URL.
Hopefully it works.
If they need further proof I'll say here is my stream and here is the timestamp.
Why didn't you press the button though?
Because you don't have to.
I didn't press it for any of the other streams.
I think it's just in case something like this happens.
Oh yeah, let's change it to 3 out of 4.
Thank you.
Are you sure?
Yeah.
I'll get it.
Don't worry guys.
Yeah, I'll get it.
I can't believe that happened.
Time to get D?
Yeah, I guess so.
I don't know how to feel about that because I'm nervous if I didn't get it or not.
I'm nervous.
I'm like I don't feel satisfied even though it was such a crazy win.
I don't feel satisfied.
Please put it in my cart.
There it is!
OK.
We're good.
There we go.
Oh my gosh!
You guys!
That was so awesome.
I can't believe I got two balls.
Two times in a row!
And then what?
The first time the ball got knocked out of the thing.
Craziness.
I'm almost out of tea.
I got an Arizona tea today.
Wow, they're all in use.
Limited stock.
Which one should we do?
Oh my god, all the 4000s are in use!
This one has two people waiting.
Wait, I can just play it.
I get in line though, right?
For this one.
Aesthetic green tea.
I've heard Arizona tea is really nice.
It's like...
If you want green tea...
Like a real green tea flavor...
Then don't...
It's not the tea.
You know?
But if you're wanting kind of a sweet tea flavor...
It has honey and stuff in it.
Yeah, it's really sugary.
I don't get them often.
I'm struggling hard to get this Yui.
You got this, Fleshy!
Is this person still going?
I'm in the queue.
This is D, right?
Yeah, D.
I'm in the queue!
It's a very good beverage, but yeah, not standard green tea.
Oh, I love the mango juice one.
It's so good, right?
You like Japanese green tea?
Yeah!
I love it.
Yummy, yummy.
Ahem.
Hi, D.
Oh my gosh.
It's the Shagohan.
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh, I can't wait to display all of these in my cabinet.
And then...
I don't think I will probably...
Nyaru!
Thanks for the raid!
Thank you!
Hello!
Welcome back!
Oh, they're back.
Welcome, welcome!
Thanks for the five gifted!
What if you went back to the 500 points?
Murphy, thanks for the gifted!
You guys, we just had a crazy play.
I'm telling you.
Frog for Robin, thanks for the five gifted!
Sirstreak, thanks for the five gifted!
You guys are too generous.
Thank you, thank you.
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you guys!
Try the 500 TP.
I think this person... Oh, I thought they were going to get two balls.
I'm a professional ball holder.
Nobody can have two balls but me.
I
know I had to catch your bots lately with my new schedule.
Customer Johnson!
Congrats on your 3.0.
It's nice to see big indie streamers like yourself help promote small time business in my house.
Stop it!
You think they're going to... Oh!
Is it my turn?
No, just kidding.
I saw waiting zero.
Oh wait, it is my turn!
Oh my gosh, it's my turn!
Wait!
Wait, they just... They gave up, I think.
They gave up, I think.
Oh my god.
No way!
I have an XP!
This is insanity!
Where did the other ball go though?
Where did it go?
Alright, come on in the middle!
Oh my gosh, is this one really rigged?
Why are they all getting stuck on the sides?
Oh, it went back in the dish.
Aw man.
Nappy!
Thanks for the gift!
It's all in the wrists, my limp wrists.
600 something thousand.
I'm living for this ambiance, honestly.
It's so funny.
I don't know if it's as loud for you guys as it is for me.
OK!
My ghost, she lost a ball.
You can call me Jojolion.
Nappy, thanks for another gifted!
Was it an extra?
I thought he had only one.
Oh come on!
This one's crazy!
Oh my gosh, he had four.
I thought he was missing.
Wait, he had four?
Guys, this might not be the one.
I have two chances left.
Single ball.
Come on!
So close.
I think it gets harder the more that stack up in there because they all start bouncing off of each other.
The other balls make yours bounce too much.
I think that's actually the case.
Yeah, I think I actually... I think I scammed myself into doing this one.
How many balls do you need to get the prize?
You just need to get it in this little red circle right here in the middle.
Yeah, this is actually harder.
Maybe I scammed myself.
I don't think this one has assist mode.
It's starting to block the middle.
You can do it!
If you believe in me...
I believe in me!
Two balls!
One ball!
Go ball go!
Into the middle!
So close!
We were so close.
It moved.
It was so close.
Dang.
Oh wait, I have enough for one more.
I can still get one in.
Next ball.
One more!
Oh my god!
What the... Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I didn't know that I accidentally hit it.
It's grandpa though.
Wait, how do you have a Wolverine?
You guys, do I buy more?
Where is the sobbing on the uncontrollably sticker?
No balls, yet it still hurts.
It's the Phantom Pain.
Give a little bit.
Give a little bit of your love.
Ok, I'll do...
I'll do 20 dollars.
I don't know how much I've spent.
Maybe like 200 dollars.
When I could have bought this.
For 60 dollars.
On my own
everybody.
I did it all on my own with only one assist.
With only one assist.
Oh my gosh, why was it so violent?
Are you kidding me?
I look like a mad person even though I didn't even start this one.
I look like the mad person because I'm continuing it.
Like seriously!
These are way less fun when actual money is on the line.
I hate to encourage, encourage gambling, but...
4000 TP!
I should be guaranteed a ball!
It's because I got the two balls before you guys.
It's because I got the two balls.
Gosh, I'm just worried about getting a ball more than anything.
Hello assist!
Can you see?
This thing is full!
It's full of balls!
Can we please clear the balls out?
Please!
Excuse me!
There should be like an alert button or something.
Old two ball mentor caught dropping balls live.
It's full of balls!
I'm no quitter.
I'm Volgin.
I go for the balls.
Guys!
Please!
It might be over chat.
It might be.
Sunk cost fallacy.
I was hoping for a miracle!
I was hoping for a miracle.
Let's see if anybody else playing gets it.
There was one person waiting.
She did the famous minced double ball grab.
I wish I did it again.
Are they going to try?
This person in line.
I wish to see.
Next person is going to get it.
I hope so!
Balls!
Do it!
No balls!
He almost had a two baller!
You got this!
That would have been me.
That's grandpa.
Why is that one?
No balls.
Does this mean not November?
Non-stop not November.
Wait!
Wait, they have it!
No way!
Wait.
Did they...
Did they get it then?
They knocked it in?
Wait, I realized that because I'm not watching I didn't see the...
Yay for you!
It fell.
It counts.
I didn't see the little thingy pop up to be like...
Congratulations!
So I didn't...
There we go.
They got it in two more tries.
It almost looks like it's sticking up though.
I wonder if it...
It feels like it didn't activate the...
You know.
The little thingy.
I'll get it to you one of these days.
No, no, no.
I'm getting my own.
It's OK.
Thank you though, but I'm getting my own.
Eventually.
Somehow.
Someway.
Somewhere.
Somehow.
In here?
Who knows.
Mercari?
I don't know.
Who cares.
Yeah, you wouldn't get the congrats since it's another player.
I realized that after I said it.
I was just like, wait, I didn't see the congrats.
Duh, because it wasn't me.
7 remaining.
3 remaining of B.
Do I duel?
Where is the 500 one?
So many of these are in use.
Oh, here it is.
It has even more now.
Look how it used to be just a couple.
It's even more now.
You think I should just do this for the rest of the time?
Are you winning, Minto?
I think so.
Are there any others that are 500?
Except that one.
We could do the 50,000.
500.
This one is also 50,000.
Oh, sorry, 5,000.
Nevermind, not 50,000.
Oh, it seems a bit more lenient, perhaps.
600 something thousand.
Oh, there is this one.
Oh wait, that's the one we were just looking at.
This one is 12,000.
Holy moly.
I think that's the only 500.
Oh wait, I could just control.
Wait, one of 13.
Oh, because it's showing me these 500s.
Just kidding.
Where did it go?
500, 500, 500, 500.
Here we go.
500, 25,600 minutes.
Grab a ping pong ball with your arm.
When the prize of the ping pong ball falls into the red hole, the display prize cannot be acquired.
What's the display prize?
Ok, let's just try it.
Thank you!
Start?
Oh my gosh, it feels so easy to miss.
I got a ball, I got a ball!
I got one, I got one, I got one.
Let's go ball!
It just immediately joined it's pack.
It joined it's team.
I got a ball!
I wonder if you have to saturate this area with balls and then...
Oh my gosh, you have to absolutely saturate this area with balls until they just eventually roll down.
Saturate with the balls, yeah.
Take a lot of balls.
I don't think I have that many balls.
I don't like this one.
Guys...
I don't know.
I'm conflicted because I want to win it, obviously.
I want to win my own, but I don't want to pay...
I don't know if I want to pay so much more to do it.
How much is it on Mercari?
Let's chat.
No!
No, no, no.
Please, actually, I will turn off super chats.
Please, no, no, no.
Mercari...
I got to make sure I'm not logged in or anything.
Okay, I'm good.
So here's Mercari Japan, right?
This is Mercari Japan, right?
Okay, these are my last searches.
Metal Gear, Power Pro, guys, because I was looking for more little snakes.
Metal Gear poster, Metal Gear...
So let's see...
Let's see...
Wait, where are all the tumblers?
Oh my gosh.
There used to be... There were like so many at the top here.
Just earlier today.
Where did all the...
Where did all the tumblers go?
Where
did all the tumblers go?
Oh my gosh, they have this!
Oh, but I want the Meiling!
Oh my gosh, no!
Okay, I'll get that later.
Nobody else buy it, please.
This is why I never do like online things, because I'm scared of...
Look at the Pico Park.
Oh my gosh, where did all the tumblers go?
Wait, actually, where did all the tumblers go?
No way.
I don't even see them under... Wait.
Huh?
What's wrong with my thing?
I don't even see them under the sold out.
Huh?
Where did they all go?
Oh wait, I'm not on the front page.
That's why.
Oh my gosh!
This is why I need to check everyday!
Look how cute the Karutan mug is!
Oh yeah, here's one.
Oh, here's another.
Oh, there's another.
Try adding Tumblr to your search.
I saw a bunch on the app.
Oh really?
That's weird.
Oh, there's Tumblr.
Oh, whoops.
Is it right there?
Huh?
What's wrong with my Mercari?
Hold on, let me go back to the beginning.
This is so weird.
Oh, there they are!
See guys, they were here.
That was weird.
That's never happened to me before.
I don't know which one is the one where... Oh, I'm guessing the green one.
So that sounds like two, right?
I'm sorry, three.
I love all that!
So these are the... This is what the Tumblr is coming.
Isn't it so cute?
It says like live snakes inside and everything.
It's so, so cute!
But it doesn't say which game it is.
So yeah, see it was like going for 50.
I spent way more, but I got them.
I got them with my own hands.
I did it myself.
How much is just one?
If I can find one...
These ones are 25.
There are two of them, but...
They are so cute.
Oh my gosh, I can't wait to get them.
I can't wait to get them!
You earned them.
Yeah, I earned them.
I earned them.
But I got more crane game points.
We shall crane game again.
Back to the cranes, everybody.
Back to the cranes!
I will get this on my own.
The cranes call.
You can get your cool Tumblr.
Believe in me that believes in you.
Thank you!
I didn't check how much I have left on my credit card.
I should be fine.
I might have to be making a payment.
We are back baby.
We are back baby!
Metal Gear is off the front page again.
I wonder if this one is the...
And it's tilted!
You guys...
That's close.
Easy one.
How do I do it?
No!
I'm in the queue.
I want to see how they do it.
Let's see.
No balls, no groceries for Tumblr.
How would you do it though?
What's the strat here?
I don't think it's DMCA.
I don't think it's loud enough.
I should be fine.
Don't worry about it.
Thanks though for worrying.
It's all good I think.
If I get hit, I probably will just say you can't monetize the stream.
But that happens to like every stream of mine.
So it's okay.
They have matte tape grip on the bars.
He's just wobbling it.
He's not moving it at all.
How would you do this one?
Turn it a little?
I would have to push it from this part here right?
Like this little corner here maybe?
From the back you want to swipe it close to the corner.
Oh they are
trying.
Oh they are really close!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I think...it feels like they are not gonna...I feel like they are...I can't tell.
It moved, but is it moving in the correct direction?
It needs to go.
I can't tell.
Stop rooting for them.
I want to root for everybody!
Go, go, go!
Yeah, they might flip it down and flat.
I know, that's how I'm feeling.
I feel like they need to go for this corner instead.
But it's harder to see.
Oh,
they listened to me.
They actually listened to me.
Oh my gosh!
You think they will win?
As long as they don't give up.
Go, go, go!
The weight distribution seems weird.
Right?
It's weird that it's like...
Not the actual product either, you know?
So they could be putting like bricks in here.
And we wouldn't even know.
Right?
Like...
Use the right claw to drag the corner on the bar that's closest to the left.
This one?
Let's see!
The weight distribution is really weird.
Huh?
But it's almost flat again.
It's almost bad.
It's almost back to being flat again I feel.
Could be the material on the bars too.
Potentially.
Wait, flat is good?
My turn?
Wait, you want to get it flat then lift it.
Wait, huh?
Which part do I aim for?
Oh my gosh.
I'm scared!
Oh my god.
Stuck diagonally is really hard.
Lift the corner that is sticking up.
Ok, this one?
This one?
Oh gosh.
Uh...
Nice push.
It didn't move.
Oh gosh.
Did I go too far?
Aim for the front?
Wait, which is the front?
Oh dang it.
Stay close to the left.
It's so heavy.
The front is the front.
Maybe like here?
There is a little more to the left.
A little to the left.
That was a fun game.
Oh my gosh.
It's full of bricks.
This grandpa used to have one of those lights.
Wait, I thought I pressed start already.
Ok, there we go.
Do you think I can push it down?
From the...from right here?
Do you think I can push it down or no?
Barely grabbed the corner.
Sometimes it works.
Ok, how wide is this open?
It's hard for me to gauge sometimes.
Like if I push...
If I push...
Well, I think it's actually...no, I don't think it would work.
Trying to get one of the corners, like this one, but it's tricky for me.
Oh, ok.
People are lining up.
It's ok.
I'll keep going.
Oh, did I go too far?
Did I go too far?
Oh, it's so heavy!
I went too far to the right, I think.
Ok, hold on.
Start!
Maybe like there, ok.
Might be too far to the left?
I'm getting a feel of it.
Oh,
no.
I didn't move at all!
Not far enough to the left, seriously?
That guy in the background, I don't think so.
It's like the people in this arcade are talking to me for real.
That's a little awkward.
Bold strategies.
I think I...
How did it just like...
How did it just...
That's a move just a bit more to the front, ok.
Hey, baby.
Oops, wait.
Will that be ok?
Oh god.
I think I'm stabbing the machine.
This one!
I'm stabbing it.
I'm killing it.
It's fine.
1, 2, 3, 4.
How am I... Am I doing this right?
I feel like I'm not doing it at all.
Align the claw to the front bar.
Drop it right behind this.
So drop it right here.
Like right there.
Thanks guys.
I don't mind the backseating so much for this because I don't have any experience.
Oh!
What am I... Where should I position it more at?
The claw is so limp, I know.
I have no confidence.
Real sumimasen moment.
For real.
A bit forward.
I think you guys gotta be more specific.
I don't know what forward.
If you're talking forward here or forward here.
If you guys are trying to help, try to be as specific as possible.
Maybe.
It's gonna touch it.
It's just like... It brushed fingers.
Still not close enough to the bar.
Really?
I think so.
It's angled and low strength of the claw.
Staff-san!
Sumimasen!
This is difficult.
I can't do it.
Staff-san!
Staff-san, where are you?
Is the back lighter to lift?
Let's try it.
Maybe I went over too far, but that's ok.
Let's see what it looks like if I try to lift up the back.
It...
It's a fucking lip-armed toreba machine!
Why are you so limp?
Maybe I gotta sweet talk it.
How do you turn on a claw machine?
How do you turn one on?
Oh, toreba machine.
You have such long claws.
And call it a good boy?
Oh, you good boy, you.
Toreba machine.
You have such long...
arms that will reach and grab and grab my thing.
Grab it!
No!
Toreba!
Grab it!
Toreba machine.
Toreba machine, I please and beg of you.
I please and beg of you, please.
Toreba machine.
Wait, so am I centering it or am I staying to the left?
I'm confused.
So I center it instead of staying to the left?
Oh.
Tetris.
Okay.
Alright.
Toreba, be a good boy.
It literally doesn't do anything.
It's such a scam.
It literally just tickles it.
It's so annoying.
Oh my gosh.
Got any metal gears inside that claw mechanism?
I don't think the arms have enough strength.
Centering what?
What does that mean?
Oops.
Like centering in here?
Like this?
I wasn't exactly centering my...
Oh please staff, come here.
I think it's stuck for real.
No matter what I do, it doesn't touch.
It doesn't do anything.
I don't think it budges anymore.
I think it's stuck.
Staff, help!
Help!
Everybody spam the cat!
In the first camera, align the vertical part of the right claw with the right corner.
This here?
Then in the second, aim for the corner sticking up.
Yeah?
Okay, I'll try.
Wait, which corner?
This one or this one?
Oh no!
Right most corner.
Oh shoot, sorry there was lag.
Sorry there was lag.
That was good.
It twitched.
Help!
Someone, staff!
Start.
1, 2, 3 That's not so bad.
Okay.
It's too heavy.
These claws are so weak.
These claws are way too weak, man.
This one sucks.
I miss the balls.
I miss the takoyaki balls.
Gosh!
Oh, I was not far over enough.
Not bad.
You guys!
Oh my god!
What do I do now?
Now lift from the front?
From here?
From right here?
It's still kind of...almost there.
Lift up from here.
Can I...should I...
My grandpa used to have one of those.
Okay, come on.
Come on.
Come on!
Tumbler D!
Oh, so close.
So close, so close.
Maybe a little closer to the front bar.
Yeah, the background chatter is on loop.
I'm going to turn it off actually because I'm kind of sick of hearing it.
It's just noisy.
Oh my gosh, I can hear again.
I can hear again.
What about his grandpa?
We'll never know.
I was not...
The lag in this is so stinky.
It gets me every time.
1, 2, 3, stop.
1, 2, stop.
No!
It's diagonal again!
It's good?
Is this really good?
But it's diagonal again.
Guys,
I can't stab it.
Look, it won't fall through the back.
It won't.
I don't think stabbing the butt will work.
I really don't think so.
I don't think stabbing the back will work.
I think it's too weak.
Please!
What the hell?
It doesn't even move!
Oh my gosh.
It's so...
Does
it say assist available?
I thought it did.
Zero, one.
Line up the inner part of the claw.
It gets leverage on the package.
Be the claw.
You can make it 1, 1.
I could.
I feel like the people working here are such masochists.
Oh man.
I had so much hope.
And now I lost all of it.
Oh wait, say this.
Yeah.
Not masochist.
It doesn't do anything.
Yeah, I meant say this.
Sorry.
It doesn't do anything.
I give up.
I think I give up.
Maybe I go back to the balls.
I wanted to end on a win.
Let's see how it's looking.
It's in use.
Oh my gosh.
I
always like this.
Oh my god, why is it always like this?
Did they have the two balls?
Oh damn.
Another lost soul.
At least with the balls it feels like I might win eventually.
Unlike with this.
Unlike with the other one.
I feel so... My spirit is so down.
Even though we won 3 out of 4.
3 out of 4.
I tried.
I did try.
I wanna... Should I get in line?
I want them to clear it though.
Yeah, I'm really tired.
Sorry, I've had a migraine all day.
I don't know if it's a migraine.
It doesn't feel like my normal migraines.
Just had a headache all day, so...
I had fun.
I'm just kind of...
You can play the takoyaki general prize ones?
Oh, that's true.
You're right.
I like the background in this one.
It's so cool.
Let's see.
Takoyaki.
Takoyakis.
Oh, wait, where are all the takoyaki?
Where are all the takoyakis?
Huh?
Wait, they took away the takoyakis.
Where are they?
I already changed it.
Where are the takoyakis?
Huh?
No.
Where's the takoyakis?
No!
Is Osaka one really easy?
I doubted it for some reason.
For some reason, I doubted.
Oh, no.
I don't think this is easy at all.
He's probably made of steel.
304 is good.
Hope your head feels better.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Sorry if I'm like...
You know, low energy past couple of days.
Just haven't been feeling well.
Where are they?
Refresh.
Oh, there's one.
There's one.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, my goodness.
It's scaring me.
We have no takoyakis.
I'm scared though, because...
This one looks like it's easy to pop out.
And also...
What if I don't grab a ball?
Okay, I'm gonna try it once.
Where's the crane?
Hello?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my gosh.
Why is it all the way back there?
This one is so violent.
This one is terrible.
This one is so terrible.
No balls.
My real reaction.
This one robs me so many times.
Oh, no.
Let's try a different one.
Yeah, I'm leaving this one.
Nobody wants to play this one.
Nobody is waiting for this one.
Get me out of here.
Back to the...
It sent me home.
Just won that previous one?
What?
This one?
Oh, you did.
It seems like it.
Good job.
Thanks for your help though, Ayu.
I hope you enjoy your Tumblr.
Please, if you are trying to win these for me...
No!
I'm getting them my own.
It's okay.
If you win, it's yours.
It's yours.
Please don't give it to me.
You earned it.
It's yours.
I want to win it on my own.
How will they do it?
How do they put it...
Together though.
They are putting more bricks in.
They are like, too easy.
We got to fill it up with bricks.
I've started to get too many things.
Sometimes I get multiples of stuff and I'm like...
My maid cafe isn't so large, so I'm actually running out of space.
I have several full boxes of fan letters and things.
I'm trying to find a way to scrapbook them.
And then other gifts that I'm like, I don't know what to...
I want to put these somewhere, but I have no space to put them anywhere.
So I'm just kind of like...
So please don't send to me.
I might have to start declining gifts at conventions and stuff.
Because I appreciate it so much, but I'm so out of room.
Actually, it's so bad.
It's actually so bad.
I have no more space.
Suffering from success, I know.
And it makes me so sad because I love receiving people's gifts and stuff.
But I have no more space.
My place is so messy because I can't put anything anywhere else.
So I just have boxes everywhere.
Let's see.
What was this one?
The 1800.
It's another...
It's a different one.
It's a different...
This one looks cleaner, maybe.
Storage unit.
I can't even fit all my MGS stuff in the...
I bought a cabinet specifically for displaying Metal Gear stuff.
And I can't even fit all my stuff in it.
Oh gosh.
I sent not gifts, but dollar-dollar bills for you to take to the strip club.
Thanks there, Crash.
Let's go!
Let's try this one.
Okay, scoop them up!
Scoop it up!
Scoop, scoop, scoop!
Get scooped, little ball!
Get scooped!
Oh my gosh.
It got scooped.
Let's go right into the red!
Right into the red hole!
You guys, this one might be doable!
Oh my gosh!
Start.
Get...
Scooped!
Get scooped!
It's a little violent sometimes.
Nice, nice, nice!
Hope restored!
Please!
He's dancing.
Okay, that's fine.
Get...
Wait.
Time.
Start.
There we go.
Time for the scoopening!
The scoop!
Oh we almost double scooped.
Get scooped!
And drop!
That one was a clean drop though, honestly.
That was such a clean drop.
You guys, I learned today...
I don't do well with crane games.
But scoop games...
I don't mind so much.
It sounds like squid games.
But scooping games...
Scoop games...
Double scoop!
You guys, we got the double scoop!
Oh shoot!
We got double scooped!
Holy moly!
How do we keep getting two balls?
Two ball mean to let it again.
I don't know how I keep doing this.
I don't know how I keep doing...
Oh shoot.
I did not mean to go that far.
Get scooped!
Right back into that hole.
She can't keep getting away with this.
I'm cheating the system.
I'm double scoop... I'm double dipping.
I'm double dipping.
Can you guys move your cats please?
So I can see.
There we go.
I think.
Maybe?
A scoop.
Sticker spam.
Guys.
Guys, this feels doable.
Perhaps, maybe.
Oh my gosh.
So close!
We're gonna get him!
We're gonna get Tumblr D!
I am on Tumblr D, right?
OK, good.
Oh my goodness, violence.
What if I like dump out everything?
Are you winning, Minto?
I don't know.
Am I winning, you guys?
Am I winning?
Tumblr D.
Yeah, I am.
You're a winner to me.
Thanks.
You're winning at life?
I'm dead.
I'm winning at afterlife.
Maybe.
I did at least do one crane game that I successfully got.
So, I think that's a win.
You know?
We did one crane game.
Oh my goodness.
Am I gonna have to pay for this one again?
Do balls count as crane game?
Get scooped.
A win is a win.
Guys,
I don't know.
I'm starting to feel...
I'm starting to feel a little bit bad about this one.
Get scooped.
I like to do that to my cat, Pies.
I like to grab her and I'm like scoop.
Because she hates being held.
So, I call it her getting scooped.
And I'm like scoop.
You need a double scooper.
I do.
Oh gosh.
Guys, I was hopeful at first.
I'm not so hopeful anymore.
Scoop.
It must come sometime to jam today.
It's creating a snowman.
No!
I'm creating a snowman.
I'm just creating a snowman.
Do you wanna build a snowman?
Let's make a snowman.
Thanks for the encouragement, cats.
Recreating Mt.
Fuji.
Guys, this is it.
I don't think this is it.
I think...
Oh my goodness.
How far will they stack before it tumbles down?
We need to make a lot of noise.
When will the avalanche happen?
What do I do?
Do I buy more?
Can't end on a loss.
OK!
I'm glad I don't pay for gacha games.
Oh god, please.
Please!
Oh we got it.
OK, I'm not gonna cry.
But my eyes will still be watering.
At
least I get the ball with this one.
It bounced!
We can keep going!
I'm buying this next time I have my card for sure.
The rugs and the plushies.
Hell no, I'm not putting myself through this hell again.
A lot of balls in this machine.
The
avalanche.
The collapse of society.
They will refill it?
Really?
OK.
I spent another 20 dollars for these points.
In case you're curious.
If you're like how much was the points she bought worth?
It was 20 dollars.
Oh my god!
Let me keep going.
Fuji grows.
The society is rebuilt.
We rebuild society.
Oh my gosh, I want to like shake my monitor.
Triple!
No...
Oh my gosh!
We almost had a triple!
The dang thing shook!
We had three balls!
I can't believe it!
Did we lose one or did they both go back into the thing?
I wonder.
We were robbed of the three balls.
I thought we had another three.
Try not moving up so high.
What do you mean?
Oh my gosh!
It's starting to roll.
I don't control this part.
I can only control when I grab the balls.
I can't control anything else.
Where it drops.
I can only control how it grabs the balls.
Yeah, otherwise I would definitely not be placing it where it goes.
Why do you have to shake?
We had double balls!
I can only control when I grab the balls.
We're gonna run out of balls at this point.
Surely Toreba would see this and be like, oh yeah, our game is a little unfair.
Like Vulcan and Ivan.
Absolutely...
We have a double?
Oh my gosh, it looks like I'm grabbing tits.
Go!
B-Release!
Free the tits!
So close!
Oh my gosh.
It's like I grabbed two little birds.
You know the birds called the tits?
We know the birds.
Yeah, I'm sure you do.
Oh my gosh, it's so aggressive.
It's so aggressive.
Guys, I don't know.
You can win by flipping the wok.
Can you actually, I wonder.
We're gonna run out of balls.
Please!
I look like an insane person right now.
I think the thing is broken!
Wait, no balls left?
You win a prize?
No, I don't think that's true.
I think it only is if you...
You win the prize of being a pathetic, sad, sad person.
Who couldn't even fill up a hole.
When you have this many balls.
Please!
Wait, rules say zero balls equals a win?
So close!
271, wow.
It's on the back wall.
How can you read that?
I only see...
I only see it saying about the...
About it going into the red.
Win the prize when there are zero ping pong...
I see!
It's the two cameras.
Oh, my bad.
Here we go.
I guess we'll win.
Oh wait, I have to buy more.
Guys, this is the last one.
Before I have to buy more.
The gacha pity reel.
I hope
I get a ball.
What if I don't get one?
That was so close.
It's starting to get really aggressive.
It's starting to get angry at me for trying so hard.
It's starting to get so jumpy.
10 more dollars, ok.
Do 10 more dollars.
I don't know what's more pathetic.
The crane game or this?
I don't know.
Will I even feel good about winning this?
I have no idea.
In the end...
In the end, when it's all said and done, will I even feel good about this?
Who knows?
I feel like, oh yeah.
I earned it myself.
Get that tumbler.
Let's go!
One more.
Hold on, I'm going to check my bank account real quick.
One second.
Hold on, let me add the calculator.
The timer.
I'm ok.
At least, you know what?
I'm getting physical items and not JPEGs.
So honestly, maybe I am winning.
Some people spend this money and then their favorite game goes out of service.
Sometimes...
Sometimes people spend this money and then their favorite game goes out of service.
Speak your truth.
Yeah!
Remember
this prize.
Remember this feeling.
This feeling of...
Absolute...
Please, I need closure for the tumblers.
Thank you.
Sounds pretty dire.
We have four more that we need to get and then we will have the prize in our hands.
But not by...
Not by luck.
But by...
By pity.
Literal pity.
How can I... How is that ending on...
How is that ending on a win?
I don't even know.
Oh my god.
We take those.
We take those!
Not pity.
Determination.
Yeah!
Not pity!
Determination!
Yeah!
The PNGs play video games and sometimes reads what I said.
Wait a second.
Have I the gacha?
I bet the staff member is watching this right now.
Oh my god!
Stop being so aggressive please!
Please...
Don't feed the gambling problem.
This is not...
This is... The gambling...
This is... No.
I will never...
I don't have a problem because I'm not feeling the high.
I'm just feeling... I'm feeling every low possible.
Two balls!
Oh my gosh!
We still grabbed it.
I'm feeling every low possible.
I don't feel like... I'm feeling the gambling high baby!
I'm feeling all the lows right now.
This is it.
The final boss.
I have to buy more.
My friend is rubbing it in my face.
They're like, I paid $20 for two tumblers.
How much did you spend?
I'm gonna cry myself to sleep tonight.
Why am I such a loser?
First try.
Oh my gosh, I even bought extra just in case.
That's it!
There's no more balls!
Give me my prize!
They were watching.
The staff was literally watching and was laughing at my pain.
They were like, she's gonna run out eventually.
This is disgracing that thing clean right now.
It pisses me off.
It pisses me off!
I have literal tears running down my face.
Oh my god.
There they are!
A, B, C, D!
Good job entertaining people who weren't even watching the stream.
That's my Yoshi.
They're like, oh brother, this guy stinks!
Congrats on getting 4 for 4!
Thank you!
My luck, everybody.
My luck.
At least with the balls.
Golly.
Laughing at me.
Money well spent.
I can't wait for the plushies and the carpet or the little rugs to come out.
I can't wait to happily go to Mercari.
I can't wait to happily go to Mercari and click buy.
And the price will probably be like 3000 yen.
And I'm like, perfect.
How much did I spend?
I spent... I love Metal Gear so much.
I really wanted to buy a Metal Gear Solid 4 poster.
But I don't think I will now.
I still have to pay for my game.
That's really gonna make me go broke.
But...
I spent $300.
So...
This was a choice.
A financial choice of my own doing.
I
have some regrets.
But boy golly, it's gonna feel good when that comes in the mail.
What if you release merch to make back some money?
Thank you!
Yeah, I should probably contact the people that are supposed to be releasing my merch.
Because that all came out of pocket too.
And so, I haven't made any of that.
I had to put all that up front.
So...
Financial decisions.
Sell your own tumblers.
No!
What?
Sell them?
They are literally being...
Well, I would say they are being buried with me.
I'm going to exhume my body and I'm going to bury...
I'm going to put those tumblers in my fucking grave.
Excuse me?
Tumblers.
Why did you say...
I'm gonna make everybody experience this.
This is how you get...
You have to play these games too.
To win the minto tumblers.
Oh my gosh, I was even looking at new mics today too.
Okay.
I'm gonna go eat indomie for dinner.
And for the rest of the week too.
Orion, welcome to Babusha, thank you.
Nah, all jokes aside, I'm doing fine.
So don't feel like you have to donate or anything.
It's okay.
I'm all good.
This wasn't good fun.
Like I said, I don't spend money on gacha games or anything.
So this kind of felt like...
Like the real gacha person experience.
How do you do it?
Minto tumblers would be so cute.
I'd buy one to enjoy...
My mornings with Minto.
Raitido!
Congrats on the tumblers, Minto.
You'll always be a winner to me.
Thank you!
I don't even want to check the group chat right now.
It has 9 plus messages.
Unrelated to what you spent today, I just want to reward you for an entertaining stream.
I'm glad you had fun.
If you had fun at my suffering...
That's okay.
You know what?
That's why I'm a streamer.
Never back down, never what?
New equipment incoming.
How's your mic hunt going?
Played
the crane games too.
Won a Crayola Shark plushie and Marvel Chibi Heroes.
You know, there's probably some people who spend just as much as me...
On the plushies at round 1, probably.
You know?
What's so good about it?
Stop it!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Congrats, thank you.
Please stop.
You've said too much today already, please.
Thank you!
Okay.
Well, thank you guys for all the encouragement.
Thank you for everybody who tried to even help me...
With the...
With the... What's it called?
The crane game.
You guys tried really hard.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you guys for enabling me to do these stupid streams.
I don't like doing them very much because it's just...
I feel of course it's like a waste of your money.
Especially if it's like...
If it's...
Like luck based with the balls, you know?
But I really appreciate it...
For you guys helping me out and encouraging me.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not gonna get caught.